♪
[Lisa] This little reunion
about to crack
- we got the whole crew back!
[Dewayne] Really bitch?
A cabin in the woods?
♪ Now let's get it all in
perspective ♪
♪ For all y'all enjoyment
a song y'all... ♪
[Nnamdi] You still a slave
to the white man?
[King] Y'all got to stop calling
my wife the white man alright?
♪ Newness, here's the anthem ♪
♪ Put your hand up that you
shoot with ♪
[Allison] Ten! That is what we
do on Juneteenth!
(slaps)
(power outage)
- Oh hell nah!
[Allison] Where are you going?
[King] To look for the fuse box.
[Dewayne] What kind of
house is this?
♪
[Dewayne] No, no thank you.
- The Blackening?
[Allison] Woah...
[King] Jim Crow Monopoly.
[Shawn] Shit probably runs
on racism
(static)
[Blackening] Pick a card
and save Morgan.
- What did he mean save Morgan?
(static)
(yelling)
[Blackening] Refuse to play
and she dies.
♪
- I think we have
to play the game.
[Lisa] In your predicament
- the Black character is always
the first to die.
- I will spare your lives if
you sacrifice
- the person you deem
the Blackest.
[Allison] The Blackest?
[Nnamdi] Nobody should
judge anybody in here.
[Blackening] You have two
minutes to decide.
[King] Shanika. She say nigga
the most.
[Shanika] Nigga!
- See?
Dewayne!
[Dewayne] Y'all can't
pick me!
- I'm gay.
[Allison] Clifton?
[Lisa] Yeah.
[Clifton] I can prove I'm
not the Blackest.
- Prove it!
- I've never seen Friday.
- [Nnamdi] The f-
- ♪
I voted for Trump.
(gasp)
What?
Twice.
(arguing)
♪ big money, playboy,
your time's up ♪
[Dewayne] We need a plan.
-[Lisa] I'm going to say it.
-[Allison] Don't you dare!
- We...
- Don't say this dumb shit.
- We have to split up.
(group moaning)
(static)
[Blackening] Your time
has run out
- It's time to die.
(door creaking)
(arrow whizzing)
(yelling)
[King] There's a crazy person
out here hunting us.
(glass shattering)
[King] You got Rosa Parks
on your shirt, right?
- We should be sitting
down right now?
- I mean...
that's exactly what she did.
- Nigga, shut up!
♪ Made you look ♪
(gunshot)
(pounding)
[Lisa] Why Black women got to
save everyone
- all the god damn time!
♪ Aw, made you look ♪
♪
-♪
-(door creaks)
[Morgan] You, stop playing.
♪
- I got a gun.
Damn
(grunts)
That's too DMX.
What am I doing?
♪